من جهته قال المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي
دانييل هاجي ان هناك عمليات نفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لاستعاده الرهاءن في وقت تم
فيه ايقاف عمليات اخرى واضاف ان هناك
عمليات مختلفه على الطاوله لتحقيق
ذلك
المخطوفون جهود عليا ووطنيه لا اريد ان
اوضح العمليات التي نقوم بها في
الاستخبارات والعمليات وايضا في ماضي كانت
هناك العدد من العمليات ولم ننشرها وهناك
عمليات اوقفنا وهذا ونحن نعمل بذلك ساعات
طويله وخلال
اليوم وايضا خلال التقييمات بالقيادات
ونسان الون في القياده المخطوفين و رئيس
الاركان ايضا هناك عمليات مختلفه على
الطاوله انضموا الينا من تل ابيب مراسل
جزيره احمد هزيم احمد قول المتحدث العسكري
الاسرائيلي بان هنالك خطط عديده موضوعه
على الطاوله لتحرير المحتجزين لدى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما وقعه في الداخل
الاسرائيلي خاصه انه الى حد الان لم يتم
اطلاق سراح اي من الرهائن الا عبر
التفاوض نعم فيدا هذه التصريحات اذا اخذنا
انعكاسها لدى عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
لدى قطاع غزه والالاف ممن يدعمونهم هم هي
بالضبط ما يخشونه هم يقولون اي عائلات
الاسرى من ان اي عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
لتحرير ذويهم لن تؤدي الى سوى عوده ذويهم
في توابيت وعوده ذويهم قتل وان السبيل
الوحيد الذي يضغطون من اجله ويتظاهرون من
اجله هو عوده هؤلاء عبر صفقات تبادل
الاسرى مع حركه حماس والموافقه اي موافقه
اسرائيل اس على المقترحات التي تقدم من
الوسطاء واخرها المقترح القطري
لتسليم لتسلم ذويهم وان هذه الصفقات هي
وحدها القادره على ارجاع ذويهم وهم احياء
لذا هذه التصريحات تثير لديهم قلق كبير
تثير لديهم مخاوف عده خصوصا في ظل تعنت
الائتلاف الحاكم بنيامين نتنياهو وحلفائه
في اقصى اليمين مثل بين كفير و سموتريش
على استمرار هذه الحرب دون توقف حتى تحقيق
ما يقولون انها اهدافها وهو القضاء الكلي
على حركه حماس وتحرير الرائ عبل العمليات
العسكريه لذا فدا فان ه اي انطباع هذه
التصريحات من قبل هجار على اهالي الاسرى
سيكون انطباعا او يتكون له اثار سلبيه
للغايه